une tournée pour améliorer la prévention
santé dans les transports routiers
c'est l'objectif du plan transportez
vous bien ce camion se rend directement
sur les lieux de travail des employés
comme ici à trappes pour ces salariés se
faire ausculter est loin d'être un
réflexe tout simplement par manque de
temps et car ils sont forcément sur les
routes et que pour eux allait voir ce
qu'on allait voir un médecin c'est pas
forcément quelque chose qui font
régulièrement
selon une récente étude réalisée par
l'ifop 53 % des salariés du secteur
disent n'avoir aucune action de
prévention dans leur entreprise
pourtant ces habitués de la route
rencontre de nombreux problèmes de santé
le dos un an d'arrêt au nom de mi temps
thérapeutique et là ça va faire un an je
suis je suis j'ai repris mon temps
complet c'est porter des charges lourdes
conduire toute la journée
tout ce qui est lié au travail de
transport de marchandises les bras les
épaules physique quoi l'enjeu de cette
tournée mieux faire connaître les
actions de prévention et des services
d'accompagnement mises en place par leur
complémentaire santé
la déformation qui sont adaptés pour eux
sur la qualité pour évaluer leur qualité
de sommeil pour évaluer leur risque
cardiovasculaire diabète
cette tournée a duré deux mois 40
entreprises ont joué le jeu sur tout le
territoire français